Bhalla Mahendran being the acting
returning officer appear above election
do hereby give notice that the number of
words recorded for each candidate at the
said election is as follows Barron John
Charles the Conservative Party candidate
twenty-seven thousand three hundred and
eighty one block Kate Katie
Rita Labour Party thirteen thousand nine
hundred and eighty-one Harrison Antonia
Michelle Liberal Democrats 1548 Hughes
Tina Rose UK Independence Party 2008 the
total number of ballot papers rejected
121 the total electorate being 69
thousand one hundred and forty nine
Barack papers issued 45066 and the
turnout being 65 thousand sixty five
point one seven and I do hereby declare
that Baron John Charles is duly elected
as Member of Parliament for the Basildon
and Billerica constituency
[Applause]
[Music]
right can I am first of all thank the
electorate of bezel dan and Billericay
for putting their trust in me one more
time it's a great honor arm and you team
to be elected as the Member of
Parliament and I thank them very much
indeed I will continue my team and I
will continue to represent all our
constituents however they voted and
whether they voted or not and we will
continue to do that um I hope for the
next five years we'll see what happens
arm later on can I also thank the
returning officer and his team are both
here tonight but also in the polling
stations across the constituency a great
job done and a very very rapid count so
our congratulations to all concern my
only complaint and I've lodged it
formally is that there were no jelly
babies here tonight but I've already
made that known um can i meanwhile thank
my team actually fantastic team I
couldn't ask for a better team that's
new pay rises by the way not this time
anyway but a great team also activists
who came out and supported us when we
were campaigning and the high street or
hustings or wherever it was I'm blessed
to have such a good team and they never
forget to remind me how good they are as
well so that's good news as well um we
shall see how the result goes nationally
but my hope is that we can we have got
the message across that we have a
growing economy record low unemployment
real terms increases in investments in
our public services and a Conservative
government if we have the majority will
and I think we will get the majority
will follow through on a constructive
positive negotiation when it comes to
brexit but can I thank you all as I said
right at the beginning putting your
trust in me I will do my level best as I
always do as I have done over the last
16 years as your
lmp2 do my very best for all our
constituents and I wish you all well
thank you
[Applause]